and I think the greatest weapon that I
can contribute is trans joy in comedy
and talking about hard you know subjects
and really intricate moments of a
transition and try to let everybody in
to see that do you want to know
ironically who uh dislikes me the most
sometimes myself oh me too oh
yo I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's March 16 2023 we're live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and locals
share subscribe tap the notification
bell all that good stuff and if you want
to chat with us during the show you can
go to roomreport.locals.com you can
download the iOS or Android app and get
information to me live on air it is wild
what we can do on the internet these
days uh today we're gonna do a little
I would say expose on the lunacy of the
left I know that doesn't sound
particularly different than what we
might normally do around here but we're
going to be a very Harris focused show
today because Kamala Harris went on
Stephen Colbert's show last night the
quote-unquote comedy show that Stephen
Colbert hosts and she literally and I
mean the word literally everyone uses
the word literally when they don't meet
it literally but I literally mean that
Kamala Harris could not tell Stephen
Colbert what the job of the vice
president is so that's one thing we're
going to show you a couple Clips on uh
and then Sam Harris you guys remember
Sam Harris Sam Harris was once one of
the intellectual thought leaders of the
left I was sort of in that intellectual
dark web crew with him uh with Jordan
Peterson and Ben Shapiro and the
Weinstein brothers and a whole bunch of
other people uh as as sort of sane
mostly centrists mostly lefties actually
calling out the illiberalism of the woke
left that thing kind of fell apart and
Sam has just
time after time just failed on the big
issues of the day and so we've got a
Kamala Harris issue we've got a Sam
Harris issue but I want to be very clear
I will not Sully the good name of actor
Ed Harris everyone loves Ed Harris you
know Ed Harris from The Rock and some
other stuff Ed Harris is going to be
just fine today before we get to any of
that let me talk to you guys about
relief bad real quick is Joe Biden's
economy making you nauseous probably
after this week well you've got to check
out relief band relief band's the number
one FDA cleared anti-nausea wristband
that's been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness and anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and much
more whether you need everyday nausea
relief or just an occasional cure for
nausea their patented technology makes
feeling sick a thing of the past relief
band is 100 drug free and non-drowsy
they've got a A plus Better Business
Bureau rating and over a hundred
thousand satisfied customers so they're
a brand you can trust you guys know I
like to polish off the week with a nice
glass of tequila if I'm a bit nauseous
the next morning doesn't happen that
often but it could happen I'll throw on
my relief band and the post hangover
nausea is gone so if you want the band
that actually works at relieving nausea
check out relief band and we've got a
deal for you guys if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code Reuben
you'll get 20 off plus free shipping and
no questions asked money back guarantee
that's reliefband.com use promo code
Reuben for 20 off plus free shipping so
okay here we go let's just
disassemble the logic of the left and it
ain't gonna be that hard today I don't
have much of a lift that I've got to do
today because you just have to listen to
them and they disassemble it themselves
so Kamala Harris vice president Kamala
Harris who was polling at zero within
her own party when Joe Biden selected
her to be VP or actually when she
dropped out first because she was doing
so poorly After People legitimately
thought she might be the next president
she dropped out pulling at zero maybe
one percent and then Joe chose her and
we all know that this was a diversity
higher it just is what it is basically
they admitted themselves in any event
she went on Stephen Colbert's show last
night you know what I always say about
Stephen Colbert he's not really a
comedian he is basically just a piece of
the machine if he can do anything in
service of the machine he will do it so
he asked Kamala Harris I think what you
would call a softball question hey vice
president what is the job of the vice
president and well enjoy
uh there's a there's a uh in the one of
the themes of the show is that her
character uh Selena Meyer is frustrated
by the sometimes vague
duties of the role like it's a it's a
high constitutional office but it's not
prescribed so much about what you're
supposed to be doing is that ring true
like what does what is the actual role
on a daily basis as you have found it
well I have the great privilege of
serving with Joe Biden who was president
of the United States
all right
right
exactly right exactly right and and was
vice president
does he understand what it's like he
does and he is he really is a true
partner and he understands the job and
remember we came in during the height of
the pandemic there's only one person
who's this behind that Resolute desk
and the decisions that that person has
to make are the decisions that nobody
else in the country can make and he's an
extraordinary leader
[Applause]
[Music]
it's an excellent that's an excellent
answer and uh the question was what is
the job of the vice president and your
answer is part of the job I'm guessing
well you know my job is to do I mean for
example I'll tell you um I was recently
in Munich at the Munich security
conference and um and the job there was
to stand up and as you know most of my
career I spent as a prosecutor and I
declared that we the United States of
America believe that Russia has
committed crimes against humanity
[Applause]
she does not know what the job of the
vice president is and frankly with her
mental Acumen that might be best I mean
he says to her it's a softball he lives
to service the machine he lives to
fellate the machine so all he's doing is
say oh it's the vice president here's
the easiest question on Earth what do
you do all day and she does not know it
would be like someone asking me Dave
what do you do for a living and me being
like well uh I know Connor over here
sits at the computer all day and does
something over there
these people are basically brain dead
and they should not be in charge of
running a McDonald's no offense to
anyone who's running a McDonald's
because you're actually far more
functional than these people by the way
as her uh when she was prosecutor she
was Attorney General of California
before she was Senator she put 1900
people in jail for is that just for
smoking weed
that's just for weed related offenses so
that's what she's doing even though she
was always joking that she smokes weed
herself or at least did smoke weed or
something like that anyway this
continued discontinued because what do
they do on corporate talk shows they
bring on Democrats to try to inflate
them although they often fail themselves
and then also to lie basically about
Republicans so Colbert also asked Kamala
Harris about Ron desantis's take on
Ukraine which we covered yesterday you
know he basically said is this in
America's interest and perhaps we have
to deal with some stuff at home before
saving the rest of the world but
apparently that was not good enough for
Kamala or Stephen Colbert and here we go
what do you make of
um someone like Governor DeSantis who
while there is a strain of isolationism
all throughout American history is
saying that this is not in America's
strategic interest to side with
ukrainians and offer them the material
Aid they need to defend themselves
against invading power
so as vice president I have now met with
over a hundred world leaders
presidents Prime Ministers chancellors
and kings
and when you have had the experience of
meeting and an understanding the
significance again of international
rules and norms and the importance of
the United States of America
standing firm and clear
about the significance of sovereignty
and territorial Integrity the
significance of standing firm against
any nation that would try to take by
force another Nation if you really
understand
the issues you probably would not make
statements like that
yeah because she really understands the
issues first off just the way she speaks
as if she is a third grade teacher for
the special class it's just it's so
pandering and awful now she clearly
prepared that answer but also really if
you just peel it a little bit deeper
than that is her position that any time
any country in the world does something
we don't like or may not agree with we
have to get involved if any country
anywhere was to violate anyone else's
territory sovereignty we have to be the
ones to do it and if you think I mean
the weird thing about the Ukraine thing
I understand look I'm not purely an
isolationist and I actually do believe
in peace through strength but we are so
screwy right now we are so messed up
financially and morally and culturally
I'm pretty sure that our 160 billion
dollars and the endless funding for the
weapons and everything else isn't going
to end this thing
but some people seem to think that Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris can end this
thing or is it just endless money
laundering and lies I think it's rather
that so you might go well how did we end
up in this situation how did we possibly
end up where the vice president of the
Democratic Party
really seems to know nothing about
nothing she doesn't know what her job is
and really maybe she can read some
things off cue cards but that's
basically it well how did we end up
there well I would argue that there has
been probably for the last decade a
complete and this is a depressing
situation for me to have to uh tell you
uh considering where I started from but
there has been a complete and utter
failure of the intellectual left there
once was a liberal left that made sense
the ACLU in the 70s fighting for free
speech right Skokie Illinois a lot
fighting so that self-proclaimed Nazis
could March because they believed in
free speech there was a left that made
sense JFK ask not what your country can
do for you ask what you can do for your
country there was a Democrat Party that
made sense but it has been demolished so
you end up with a President Who
basically has brain damage and a vice
president who can't explain what the job
of the vice president is and I would say
over the course of these last 10 years
we've just seen a complete Elite
decimation of whatever intellectual
piece of the left there was so now this
is the Segway to the other Harris and I
just want to say before we do this I
have tried you know I have tried Sam and
I were friends Sam Harris and I were
friends for years many dinners together
uh with with spouses and all of that
stuff so I'm not trying to be gratuitous
here but these clips were going viral
and I just don't understand how somebody
could be so wrong about so many things
whether it comes to covid or censorship
you know thanking Jack Dorsey for uh you
know getting rid of Donald Trump off
Twitter and a bunch of other stuff and
then continually doubling down on it but
maybe it does get to the heart of what
is wrong with leftism and maybe it also
gets the heart of what is wrong with the
sort of purely secular atheist position
which is that you kind of end up
believing something one way or another
all right that's enough of a lead-in on
this thing here is Sam Harris on Lex
Friedman's podcast still
illogically trying to explain his
position on vaccine is and it just
doesn't make any sense go
we're against skepticism of the safety
and efficacy of the vaccine
so people who get nervous about
the vaccine but don't fall into the
usual anti-vax Camp which I think there
was a significant yeah enough number oh
yeah they're asking they're getting
nervous I mean the sense was that you
weren't open enough to the skepticism I
understand that people have that sense
I'll tell you how I thought about it and
think about it one again it was a moving
Target so there was a point in the
timeline where
it was totally rational to expect that
the vaccines
were were both working but both they
were they were reasonably safe and that
and that covid was reasonably dangerous
and that the trade-off for basically
everyone was it was rational to get
vaccinated given how many given the
level of testing it was just obviously
reasonable to get vaccinated in
especially because there was every
reason to expect that while it wasn't a
perfectly sterilizing vaccine it was
going to knock down transmission a lot
and that matters and so it wasn't just a
personal choice you were actually being
a good citizen when you decided to run
whatever risk you you were going to run
to get vaccinated
man there's so much there uh first off
to say it was completely rational to
think that there was a point on the
timeline that it was completely rational
to think they were safe I mean it was
completely rational to think they
weren't safe they were being pushed on
everybody for a virus that had over
99.9 chance of recovery from if you were
relatively healthy if you were very
elderly or had several other
comorbidities much like you wouldn't
want to get the flu you also didn't want
to get coveted but the idea that it was
rational to think they were safe like
what happened to skepticism I thought
Skeptics I mean Sam and the and the
atheist community and that sort of
section of the secular left I thought
their entire thing was about skepticism
you don't just accept answers we're not
like those stupid religious people who
just accept that floating Sky God that
would be their General position we think
about things we question things
why did I end up questioning the vaccine
why did I not get vaccinated and clearly
that has turned out to be the correct
position and millions and millions of
other people took that same position and
now are quite happy about it there are
tons not only of people who are vaccine
injured we'll get to that in a second
but there are tons of people who now are
vaxxed who were forced to get backs who
did not want to get backs but they were
forced because of their job or having to
travel internationally whatever their
choice was that you know you eventually
got pushed into a corner and you made
your choice but there are tons of people
who are now trying to figure out ways to
detox from The Backs we know that people
who get booster after booster after
booster still are getting covered I had
Robert Malone on the show The basically
the inventor of the MRNA vaccines saying
that he at this point thinks it's going
to get way way worse that the vaccines
are actually degrading your immune
system so there was no point in the
timeline where it was totally rational
to just believe the machine but that
would be my position generally when it
comes to people like Sam it's like you
can say you're an atheist but you end up
believing in something one way or
another that was Jordan Peterson and Sam
had several debates over the years and
that was Jordan's basic argument you can
say you don't believe in anything but
your actions actually prove otherwise
um
this other idea though that he says then
I'll move on to the next clip uh about a
personal choice everything is about
personal choice when they tell you you
have to do this for the good of
everybody else you better be pretty wary
of these people back in the day if you
wanted to get vaccinated it was so that
you wouldn't get sick suddenly this
virus comes out of wherever it came up
from perhaps a lab in Wuhan funded by
Anthony fauci and suddenly you have to
do something for everyone else and you
have to stay in your house for everyone
else and you have to wear a mask for
everyone else and the rest of all of
this nonsense and it was all Bs but for
some reason he keeps going with this
here's just one more clip of this uh
here's another this is just an illogical
explanation where he's trying to refine
his position on the backs but it just
ain't right
we should all feel a civic
responsibility to be vaccinated against
egregiously awful and transmit
transmissible diseases for which we have
relatively safe vaccines
to keep those sorts of people safe and
there was a period of time when it was
thought that the vaccine could stop
transmission yes and so again all of
this is it has begun to shift
um I don't think it has shifted as much
as Brett Weinstein thinks it's shifted
but yes there are safety concerns around
the MRNA vaccines
especially for young men certainly less
worried about getting covet I've had it
once I've been vaccinated I feel like
it's like so you ask me now how do I
feel about getting the next booster
I don't know that I'm going to get the
next booster right so so I I was
somebody who was waiting in line at four
in the morning you know hoping to get
get a some overflow vaccine when it was
first available and I that was at that
point given what we knew
or given what I thought I knew based on
the best sources I could consult it was
totally rational for me to to want to
get that vaccine as as soon as I could
and now I think it's totally rational
for me to to do a a different kind of
cost benefit analysis and wonder listen
do I really need to get a booster right
you know like how many of the how many
of these boosters am I going to get for
the rest of my life really and how safe
is the MRNA vaccine for a man of my age
right and do I need to be worried about
myocarditis for you know all of that is
completely rational to talk about now
I'm actually almost speechless there's
so much double speak in there and and
really just endless nonsense and I think
what happens is
again if you just believe in the system
you just believe that these systems
exist and they somehow are inherently
good for you then you can always
rationalize everything how was it
rational say a year and a half ago to
get a virtually untested operation warp
speed pushed through vaccine that we
didn't know much about how was that
rational then when we did know for sure
that there was over 99 chance you were
going to be just fine especially I don't
know I think he's in his early 50s if
you're a relatively youngish middle-aged
healthy person and now he's saying uh
it's also rational to be skeptical about
it now but it was rational to be
skeptical about it then and and because
there's been just a complete collapse of
of any intellectual arguments on the
left on one day they'll be forcing you
to do something and telling you it's for
your own good and for societies good and
then the next day they'll tell you oh
boy well I guess we kind of screwed up
that one and who knows maybe we
shouldn't be getting boosters it's just
but it just continues I'm not going to
hit this too hard anymore but uh it just
continues they lie about everything so
you know we showed you a clip a day or
two ago about this interview that Joe
Biden did with Cal Penn from the White
Castle movie I guess he's a host on
Comedy he's is he the host of The Daily
Show now is that what it is I don't know
what he is but he's on Comedy Central
now and he did a very very ridiculously
softball interview with Joe Biden I mean
that's what they do think about where
the vice president and president are
being interviewed you got Joe Biden on
Comedy Central you got Kamala Harris on
Colbert it's interesting that they don't
get interviewed by forget me why are
they getting interviewed by uh Ben
Shapiro maybe sit down with Jordan
Peterson sit down with somebody that
might be able to challenge some of your
beliefs but okay just fine anyway they
just lie about everything and they
always move the goal posts all right so
Sam is moving the goal post there it was
rational to do this then it was rational
do this now sure I turned out to be
wrong about everything never says that
but that's sort of the subtext
and this is Joe Biden moving the goal
posts when did Joe Biden know that he
was for gay marriage it was like 1960
it's wild uh well take a look
question for you Mr President is you
codified uh support for same-sex
marriage and interracial marriages like
like ours I'm curious what your
Evolution was like on marriage equality
and what the federal government might be
able to do to protect lgbtq Americans
especially trans kids who are dealing
with all these regressive state laws
that are popping up right now
I can remember exactly where my Epiphany
was okay I hadn't thought much about it
tell you the truth and I was a I was a
senior in high school
and my dad was dropping me off I
remember about to get out of the car and
I looked to my right and two
well-dressed men in suits kissed each
other
I mean they give each other a kiss and
then one went looked like he was heading
to the DuPont building one looked like
he had the Hercules Corporation building
and I never forget I turn to look to my
dad he said Joey it's simple they love
each other
Joe Biden is claiming that in 1961
that he was for gay marriage 1961 he was
for a gay marriage he is so enlightened
Joe Biden also I don't know what the
hell Cal Penn is talking about that Joe
Biden somehow codified interracial
marriage but okay put that aside also
for some reason calpen is very
interested in having young boys chop
their genitals off or young girls chop
their breasts off without having any uh
development in their brain to know what
they're doing with their lives but okay
that's sort of leftism 101 right now
mutilation of the genitals is very high
on their hierarchy of important things
but Joe Biden again is saying in that
1961 he was for gay marriage well that's
quite bizarre because it took us about
10 seconds to find this from 2006.
I can't believe the American people
can't see through this reality have a
law the Defense of Marriage Act we've
all voted not or I voted and others said
look marriage is between a man and a
woman and states must respect that
nobody's violated that law there's been
no challenge to that law why do we need
a constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman what's the
game going on here did you support gay
marriage no Barack Obama more I support
redefining from a from a civil side what
constitutes marriage
so upsetting guys because I I believe in
Joe Biden I believe that in 1961 he was
in high school and saw two gentlemen two
well-dressed gentleman kiss and thought
I will fight for gay rights after I
leave the Jewish temple this morning and
I get out and I have uh sandwiches with
my Puerto Rican friends and I also grew
up in the uh in the hood and all of the
other nonsensical things he makes up but
somehow 50 years later he was still
fighting against gay marriage it's all
so confusing and I would just like to uh
juxtapose that with the way that they
treat Republicans when it comes to the
mainstream media because I think I've
made my case here they give you these
softball ridiculous nonsensical things
if you're a Democrat if you're
Republican they just lie about literally
everything you do and as you guys know
the main guy they're lying about these
days is the guy that they view as the
big threat and of course that is Ron
DeSantis from the free state of Florida
we shouldn't Overlook that the anti-woke
guy Ron DeSantis his ideal is Putin's
Russia where there are no gay people
where there are no women in power where
you know they're all Christians that's
how he wants to see the world that's the
world that's why they love Putin and
they love autocrat
I call it the televised mental
institution of MSNBC like really think
about how insane that is no one is
coming for the gays of Florida gays are
doing quite well here because they live
in Freedom and are treated equally under
the law Ron DeSantis is not coming for
the women or the black people or any of
it but this is what they do so now I got
one more clip for you and then we're
going to get to the Community Q a so
think about it you've got sort of the if
you take Sam Harris and say he was part
of the intellectual side of the left
making at one time good Arguments for
leftism or liberalism he's he's sort of
gone off the deep end calling for
censorship of trump etc etc uh then
you've got your Kamala harrises the type
of people that literally don't know what
their jobs are and then you've got
people like Joe Biden who literally lie
about everything and we just have the
video to prove it so where does that
leave us it leaves us with a quick clip
that I think I showed it was either
yesterday or the day before this is Anna
tomorrow on The View yelling at people
as to why they have to support Biden and
Harris because there are no arguments
left
all there is on that side of the aisle
is the constant quest for power so you
can't make a good argument for Biden and
Harris but you can basically bludgeon
people into voting for them and here's
Anna Navarro
I don't know what the hell is wrong with
Democrats listen here's the bottom line
guys
Joe Biden's going to be your nominee
stop talking about how old he is and
Kamala Harris is going to be your vice
president so stop fretting stop ringing
your hands and get behind your ticket
because on the other side your
alternative is Donald Trump or Rhonda
Santos so you tell me what you prefer
get behind the geriatric guy who can't
complete a sentence and has taken every
position on everything and lies about
absolutely everything and is clearly not
in charge and the woman who doesn't know
what her job is otherwise you're not a
good Democrat and I would just contrast
that to the way that I've tried to uh
approach what's going on on the
Republican side obviously I am voting
for a republican no matter who it is in
2024 I am voting for them as opposed to
a Democrat right you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
the Democrats have lost their mind but
as I have said to you guys many times I
am going to interview all of the
candidates we're going to try to do them
all in person I am going to treat them
all the same and at the end of the day
if you watching this right now if half
my audience votes for Trump and 30
percent votes for DeSantis and 12 votes
for Nikki Haley and seven percent uh
votes for somebody else that'll be just
fine but imagine there are people that
tune into the view to be yelled at over
who they're supposed to vote for if you
come to a different in conclusion than I
do that is just absolutely fine and
speaking of that
just yesterday we did our first of those
in-person sit-downs and I did an hour
with Nikki Haley we talked about our
agreements we talked about our
disagreements uh which mostly had to do
with foreign policy and it was all good
and I think she's a good person and
we're going to have a really nice crop
of interesting truly diverse Republicans
up there whether it is Trump or DeSantis
or vivec or Nikki or Mike Pompeo or
whoever else it might be but
unfortunately man the ship has left the
station when it comes to Sanity on the
left and on that note let's get to a
Ruben report dot locals.com Community Q
a here we go Florida man Chuck says what
do you think about all the quote-unquote
Republicans who are siding with the
Democrats regarding the censorship of
the January 6 video footage do you think
that this will be enough to finally
convince the American people to give
these career politicians the boot I mean
look people love to be punished and they
love to vote in people who never do the
right thing it's been kind of
disappointing to see a bunch of
Republicans side with the Democrats on
this that somehow we are we're revealing
State secrets and it's a security issue
and everything else it's like how about
more transparency right you people love
trans stuff except transparency that's
the one that they're not really into the
idea of leaking or not leaking allowing
this footage out which is exactly what
McCarthy did it sounded originally like
it was about 40 000 hours now it's about
sixty thousand hours it's like okay
we'll be able to look at the footage and
see actually what happened and what we
are finding out is what I think a lot of
people suspected or or knew to some
extent which is that the police and the
security at the Capitol were opening
doors for people we're literally putting
keys in locks and allowing people to
walk into the Capitol and into the
offices and moving barricades and it
certainly was not as as evil of a
terrorist Insurrection as it was framed
to be my preference would be we get more
information out there so the fact the
fact that we have some you know kind of
Limp wristed Republicans who just side
with the Democrats that you get you know
people like Mitt Romney who there is no
difference
from Mitt Romney to a Democrat at this
point they will never stand up for the
right thing but it allows Mitt Romney to
get on the talk shows and to be thought
of as a polite member of society as
opposed to a republican who actually
accomplishes something sort of like
Donald Trump sort of like Ron DeSantis
if you're a Republican and you stand up
for your principles they will try to
destroy you if you're a Republican and
you do what they want man you're going
to be on Meet the Press and they're
going to take you out to lunch in D.C
Marshall says I know you talk about
moving to Florida but what other states
would be good states to move to I mean
look Texas I think is in great shape
right now I think a few years ago you
know the fact that better World got so
close to beating Ted Cruz was a huge
huge like signal to to the good decent
people in Texas that you better pay
attention and then what happened well
Beto ended up running for governor and
got crushed so Texas I think is fully
safe I think Montana uh is doing great I
think Tennessee is doing great South
Dakota South Carolina
are doing great I think even George is
making a little more sense at least at
the gubernatorial level but I would go
look any of the states first off that
are uh that have no income tax like I
don't even mean that purely at like a
financial level because I didn't move to
Florida for the finances but now like
every month when I look at the numbers
and I'm just like yeah why did the
government need more of my money why did
Cali need another 12 from me to run the
ridiculous experiment that it's running
over there and nothing is better there
everything is actually better here but I
would say you you should go to states
that are reliably red and guess what
even if you're gay and or black they
ain't gonna come for you because people
in red States generally believe in
Freedom and if you want to live in a
blue state with high taxes and high
crime and the rest of it go for it but
yeah that's it uh vika says do you think
Bernie really did not know the
difference between equality and Equity
or is he just a he or is he just at a
Biden point in his life where he doesn't
know what he believes anymore you know
it's really interesting if you watch his
body language in that clip which we
played a couple times and if you haven't
seen it you can catch it it was on Real
Time with Bill Maher and Bill basically
said hey what's the difference between
equality and Equity he doesn't know he
kind of fumbles around you can see his
eyes kind of darting around Bill
basically explains it to him and then he
comes out on the side of equity meaning
equal opportunity as opposed to equality
uh which is equal opportunity as a as
opposed sorry as opposed just to say
as opposed to equity which is equality
of outcome but that is baked into his
socialist world view that we should be
using the levers of government so that
everyone is equal on the other side
that's socialism 101 that that's
everything he has been fighting for his
entire life I don't know that he knows
what he believes anymore you know I used
to say that Bernie was a True Believer
but it's like man if you don't know the
difference between equality and Equity
like that's basically saying to Bernie
Sanders you don't know the difference
between capitalism and socialism so he
might be at the point where he's
completely muddled I also think it's
possible that he never thought that the
woke thing and and the real radicalism
of the progressives like he was an old
school socialist that had nothing to do
with sexuality or skin color really uh
and then these guys came in behind him
and I think he probably looks at them
and and to some extent is like man what
did I usher in so when Bill really laid
it out for him he he was like oh yeah I
do I do believe in them a quality of
opportunity and it's like yeah sorry
dude you're the one that opened the door
for all these crazy people so it's it's
hard to know truly uh petunia says I
know you enjoy tequila and I haven't
been listening long enough to find out
your favorite tequila and or margarita
recipe the best margaritas I've had were
Patron in a Mexican place in Moab Utah
that's an interesting place to get a
margarita can you please share your
favorite tequila and Margarita recipe
for the locals recipe before the locals
recipe book finishes do how are we doing
on the locals recipe book we have tons
of things we're putting it together it's
all it's all happening so if you are in
the locals Community we are we are
taking recipes from you guys and we're
going to put them together in a PDF
that's going to be separate than the The
cookbook that David and I have been
working on for quite some time which
will be a full book maybe maybe we'll
make this into a binded book we'll see
but I will tell you a couple things on
the tequila and Margarita front to me
the best tequila it ain't cheap it's
about 140 bucks a bottle but Casa Azul
Reposado it is that white and blue
bottle that I've ceramic beautiful
bottle that I've brought on when we've
done some later shows a couple times
that as a sipping tequila one rock it's
just perfect and phenomenal I actually
like reposados more than I like a nejos
anejos they let sit longer so you're
going to get more of that wood taste or
that Oak taste
I like the I like the thinness and
lightness of a Reposado a little bit
more as for a margarita recipe I mean
the third third situation is basically
it you do a third tequila Dua Blanco
tequila uh Casa dragones is excellent if
you want a nice Blanco uh and a third
orange juice and a third lime juice you
can go even a little bit less on lime
juice that's like a super simple on the
Rocks Margarita you will dig it I
promise uh Curtis says uh with those who
subscribe to your belief in
self-reliance personal responsibility
and meritocracy just to name some
attributes of individuality those on the
collective side seem to be hotwired to
never change on a scale of one to ten do
you think it would take a total collapse
of freedom for this group to ever see
the light that's a great question
um so how do we get these people to wake
up right because I think if people
really understood the issues if we
really had good State education
people would understand Freedom or like
the default position should always be
freedom and then we should go okay where
do we need the government to do some
things if at all but the default
situation seems to be the reverse where
it's like government should do
everything and then you can figure out
little ways to be free outside of that
so we have to flip the whole script on
that how do we break these people
I don't know it's tough but I think
there are ways that it's happening I
mean I think that is what sort of the
the online Creator revolution has caused
right it's why more people tune into
this and and Shapiro and Crowder and a
whole bunch of other people more than
they tune into MSNBC and CNN I think
people are starting to see through the
lies
um but it's it's a serious brainwashing
situation with these leftists it really
is and I also think the proof is in the
pudding on that because if you look at
the midterms it's like
by most estimations if you're kind of
saying you should have voted for a
republican after all of these years of
covid and the rest of it and yet you
know although the Republicans got the
house back it certainly was no Red Wave
so it shows you that a certain amount of
people are still brainwashed and maybe
want to be brainwashed you know and and
that's also the effectiveness of why
calling people racists and bigots and
homophobes why it works when you do that
to everybody else the day you have your
red pill moment you go oh they're
gonna do that to me and that ain't fun
so it keeps people in kind of a
self-hostage situation Jackie says do
you think people who watch your show or
other conservative shows for hit pieces
like Media Matters ever accidentally get
red pilled or have any moments of maybe
they have a point it's funny so we know
for sure like without question that
there are Media Matters people who watch
my show every day waiting for me to slip
up or make a joke they don't like or
selectively edit something or Southern
Poverty Law Center or now News Guard
I've got them coming after me literally
an organization funded by the federal
government 750
000 100 True watches this show waiting
for me to say something so they can
basically get an article printed in the
New York Times to go after the
disinformation people of YouTube to get
us all freaking canceled and get my guys
to be fired and everything else it ain't
gonna work by the way
um
so
wait what was the question what was the
actual question there I went on a
complete tangent back me up for a second
what's that
oh do they get red pill
do they get red pills watching um I
think so I think they probably do you
know one of the funny things about that
is that back in the day when when people
would uh you know selectively edit
things that I said
um it was bothering me right it was like
it's very annoying and it's like what
can I do about it you know like what can
you do now what I find is Media Matters
and these other places they put up
exactly what I say and I'm like yeah
that is what I said because that's the
truth so I do think it's possible that
the media's matter the media matter
person watching this right now or the
Southern Poverty Law Center person
watching this right now it's like if you
really watch this you know I'll talk to
you directly right now Media Matters guy
if you're watching this right now note
I've been talking about freedom I am not
trying to get gay people I'm not trying
to get black people I believe that you
media's Media Matters person should have
the most autonomy over your life as
possible I want limited government so
that you can follow your dreams and
pursue happiness and the rest of it but
I know it's a bunch of far
crap okay uh Brooke says forgive me if I
missed it but as the founder of locals
which is now part of Rumble do you have
a comment on Stephen Crowder joining
Rumble you know I didn't even have a
chance to comment on it I I wanted to uh
I think I did tweet about it I sent I
sent one tweet out just congratulating
Crowder I'm thrilled that he's on Rumble
look what we did with locals in Rumble
was build an alternative ecosystem so
that anyone whether they agree with me
or disagree with me or like me or hate
me it has nothing to do with me we are
building parallel infrastructure so that
you as a Creator can do whatever you
want I was very happy to see that you
know after obviously there was a big
brouhaha what happened with Crowder and
daily wire and I covered a bunch of that
kind of stuff I was thrilled to see that
he said the best way for me to build my
company to build out the mug club and to
remain truly independent and monetize as
I see fit in all those things was
exactly what we've built I like that is
freaking awesome his the mug Club
subscription is built on on locals
technology he's using Rumble as his main
platform like we're really doing it and
and that was my thing all along I didn't
want to just talk about this stuff I
wanted to do some things that would
actually make a difference and we've
done just that and and by the way we've
got other major major announcements
coming like the the rumble situation is
just really hot right now and we're just
gonna keep doing it we're just gonna
keep doing it whether that means we have
to build
a messenger and a Gmail client or an
email client and a whole bunch more and
we are working on a couple other
features I know that you guys in the
locals Community one of the features you
really want is the to message each other
we're working on it we're working on it
just patient all of these things take
time but we we've got the laundry list
and we're going to do it uh Jill says
what's your favorite candy and sweet
treat
I like the ice cream I like ice cream
had a little talenti do you know about
talenti uh it's a pretty solid brand had
some talenti I love mint ice cream I
like cookies and cream I'll do a vanilla
I would do a vanilla straight up vanilla
before I would do a straight up
chocolate what do you think about that
people are going to say that's because
of racism
and maybe it is it is Kelly says if you
were president would you consider
pardoning Julian Assange uh uh freeing
him is uh oh not freeing him was what I
considered one of the largest mistakes
of the Trump presidency
um would I consider pardoning him
absolutely look I don't know that we
have all of the answers related to all
of that but what he released has now
shown us that the security state in the
United States and the FBI and the CIA
and now subsequently everything we know
about Hunter Biden's laptop and how they
lied about that and all of these things
I mean we basically have have started to
use technological and intelligence
Warfare on our own citizens so does he
deserve to not have to live where is he
now is he even in Russia anymore they
got he's in England now so I guess he
right like it it has been completely
unjust what has happened to him I should
do more on this maybe we can we'll try
to get him on show I think we tried a
long time ago it was it was very complex
and I think there's limits to what he
can say and what's that he's in jail is
he he's in jail right now I thought he
was
so Edward Snowden is in Russia and
Julian is oh right Julian Assange is in
jail all right clearly I need to do a
little more digging on this stuff and
yeah stay tuned on that uh Danielle says
before Justin was born you were soaking
up the weekends how have your weekends
changed and how have they stayed the
same since August
you know it's funny because on a weekday
around here like you know as I tell you
guys like 7 A.M I'm doing my thing with
them for an hour and it's just a great
way to start the day and everybody was
in a seriously good mood this morning
and slept well last night and they're
they're you know Justin's crawling
around Luke's rolling a little bit so
like it's just kind of fun and light in
the morning
um and then I'm doing my thing in here
and doing other shows and whatever it
might be uh during the day the weekends
are a completely different thing because
because I'm not working now it's like
it's all four of us for 48 hours and
sometimes the weekends can be more
intense because I'm I'm more involved
and all of that stuff uh this past
weekend we went to the botanical gardens
we took them to the botanical gardens
over here there was like a lily fair or
something and all these kind of nice
flowers and stuff and then we went to a
petting zoo and we got to see some
chickens and donkeys and cows and
rabbits and a bunch more you know they
don't really pay that much Justin's at
the point where he can kind of visualize
what's going on and you know he's my he
just endlessly Smiles at everything
um so we didn't we had a really nice uh
weekend but yeah my my drinking tequila
while in the pool lounging for three
hours uh on a Saturday at 2 p.m are
pretty much gone but there's a there's
another part of life that is uh I would
say kind of complete wow Nick says as a
fellow Floridian I was one wondering if
you and David had invested in solar
panels if not do you think that now is a
smart time for anyone to invest in them
since China has sole control over their
production and Supply you know it's it's
actually really interesting so obviously
Florida is the Sunshine State the house
that we bought had some solar panels
and I brought someone in to you know
basically audit the system and like tell
me what's going on here you know one of
the things that people don't realize
about solar power is if you have a
normal solar system as big as it might
be on your house or wherever it is if
it's in the field next year it's
whatever unless you have a battery like
a Tesla powerwall battery is one of the
main ones but I think Samsung makes one
a couple other companies unless you have
a battery to store that energy basically
you're taking the power from the Sun it
goes into your solar panels and then it
goes back out to the grid so you're
helping the grid offset some of the
energy but if the power was to go down
meaning if the grid went down unless you
have a battery attached to that you're
going to go down too so you could have
literally the best solar panels in the
world and unless you've got that Tesla
power wall or one of these other
batteries grid goes down you're still
going down so anyway the house did not
have a battery we I had someone audit
the system and they were like actually
these panels that you have up are pretty
much nothing they're mostly decorations
they're offsetting You by this tiny
little piece and we didn't think that
they were that they didn't look that
great quite frankly the way they were
put in so we actually removed them which
was a little bizarre because I was like
I can't believe I'm living in Florida
removing solar panels I have looked into
maybe putting up some other ones and
doing the powerwall thing uh it's all
quite pricey right now like they're
they're a major uh issues on the on the
funding of that one of the things that I
would like to talk to Governor DeSantis
about at some point when we do a longer
sit-down is should Florida maybe be
doing some more subsidies on that kind
of thing right like he doesn't love the
idea of the government subsidizing some
of this stuff but if you have a state
like Florida where we have you know
basically endless Sunshine that can be
converted into power to make us a little
bit less reliant on say China Russia Etc
uh maybe that's something that that the
government should look into so I will
talk to him about that Amy says I just
watched the movie the uh the campaign
with Will Ferrell and Zach Galifianakis
Circa 2012. have you seen it it strikes
me as far more accidentally accurate to
today's political sphere than most
documentaries today um I have not seen
it but I've heard it is excellent and
you know what Amy my commitment to you
is I will watch it this weekend and get
back to you so stay tuned on that Kathy
says what are you growing in your garden
this year
uh right this moment we don't have a ton
going on I'm working on a much bigger
Garden Project we've got some basil and
some Rosemary I'm putting in some new
citrus trees this weekend I think we got
we we got four big holes that we're
about to uh fill in I think we're gonna
do an orange lemon lime and probably
grapefruit uh I do have a mango tree
which just started fruiting which were
psyched about and we have a freaking
amazing avocado tree that's probably my
guy said he thinks it's probably about a
hundred years old uh it was in a bit of
neglect before we moved here so it took
about a year of feeding it and pruning
it and doing all the right stuff but now
that avocado tree is looking great and
uh yeah I think oh and we have two
banana trees right now with with massive
banana bushels right so I'm gonna have a
lot of bananas if anyone wants a banana
please contact us and I will I will send
you a banana milk Daphne you don't want
to send out bananas to all the people
that all right we can't send you bananas
I'm sorry uh and tinsigal says what what
if anything keeps you up at night do you
have any deep-seated worries about
locals the Reuben report or your family
life
um well on the locals front no I mean
the company's working like yes could
Google or Amazon or what like they
attack us or I don't know like but
that's not kind of what I'm worried
about in terms of what we're doing here
no I I really as I say in our we do our
weekly team meeting and every week I'm
like guys this stuff's working
everybody's working hard we're growing
like every week we Crush every number
like I feel good about the content I
feel like I'm doing what I'm supposed to
be doing so I don't worry about that I
mean
it's going to sound kind of corny I mean
the only thing that I really worry about
is like the state of the world like that
is actually what keeps me up at night or
you know just you know I'm walking the
dog or I'm pushing the kids in the in
the stroller and I'm like legitimately
like man how much longer is this
American experiment gonna go or you know
what if what if we send our guy what if
we send DeSantis out to the machine and
the machine takes him out like where
does that leave Florida all that kind of
stuff but I'm not the minutia of my life
like I'm not too worried about that and
you know as I've said like I have the
things that I want things are good we're
going to keep pushing and building and
all that stuff uh but it all of that
leads you to you gotta fight harder then
right like if you have something to
fight for this is the time to fight for
it because uh these guys just aren't
going to stop it's just it's just kind
of how it is and if you think that as a
end of the person you must fall in line
and vote for Joe Biden and kamalaris
it's like a lot of people are going to
do that but I think there's a much
better way that has nothing to do with
those people
I've enjoyed today's uh question and
answer session do do you guys have any
final thoughts today before we uh do the
post game show we got a post game show
coming up in just a couple seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com I leave you with
a cold close and I'll see everybody on
the other side and everyone else I guess
I'll see you tomorrow goodbye
[Music]
over a billion 200 trillion 200 billion
dollars
[Music]
thank you